it's only Tuesday but President Trump
like only he can has managed to send the
media and Democrats into an absolute
frenzy we'll get to the media's meltdown
over the president in a second but first
high drama in our nation's capital today
as top Democrats abruptly canceled a
spending meeting with President Trump
over a tweet Nancy Pelosi and crying
Chuck Schumer backed out of the sit-down
after the president signaled he was
unlikely to bend to their requests he'd
written that they want illegal
immigrants flooding into our country
unchecked our week on crime and wants to
substantially raise taxes I don't see a
deal that set off the lips with his
tweet this morning President Trump made
sure that today's meeting is nothing but
a photo-op these issues are far too
serious for these kinds of games mr.
president it's time to stop tweeting and
start leading as long as he remains a
destructive force it would be a waste of
everyone's time to continue working with
someone who clearly has no interest in
coming to an agreement mr. Trump held a
press conference at the White House
without Chuck and Nancy and had this to
say Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi did
not show up for a meeting today I'm not
really that surprised we have a lot of
differences that week on crime then week
on illegal immigration they want the
illegal folks to come pouring into our
border and a lot of problems of being
caused although we've stopped it to a
large extent as much as you can without
the wall which we're going to get so
they decided not to show up they've been
all talk and they've been no action and
now it's even worse now it's not even
talk the president was on the hill
earlier to rally Senate Republicans on
tax reform the budget committee advanced
the bill earlier moving it closer to the
full Senate for a vote perhaps later
this week so long your team just ditches
the meeting do you think that makes the
Democrats look weak or strong I think
they're
very strong but let me just ask you
something let me ask you something I
know you came to me first could you
think oh the Democrats are on the
defensive he asked you a question first
because I I appreciate that but didn't
the president set this off with his
tweet so they were too sensitive to read
a tweet and go to the meeting no no I
can read a tweet but the guy said I
don't see a deal so why come unless you
just come in to have a picture so they
don't want to deal the Democrats don't
want they don't want they don't want to
have a meeting where they are positioned
as begging the president Oh mr.
president oh we're so sorry Oh mr.
president what do you have to offer can
we make that's putting yourself in the
upper hand you're saying by leaving the
meeting I think they say let's have a
fair level playing field let's come into
this with good intentions good-faith
negotiations do you see it that way no I
think they should have responded by
saying we got what we wanted last time
we'll see you at 3:00 oh why not going
that because they actually did and the
president was like I'll agree with Chuck
and Nancy and the Republicans have a
scurry back and try to figure out how to
cobble together something that got us to
this place we're now a week from Friday
the government is set to shut down so I
think that they could have responded in
a different way do you think this is
just Trump's opening bid you know you're
saying Kimberly I don't see a deal but
eventually they're gonna have to get a
deal yeah I mean look wouldn't it be
nice if everyone could just work
together cooperatively to a common good
instead of a lot of the political
gamesmanship I don't know maybe one
morning I'll wake up and that'll happen
but not today and probably not tomorrow
or for the rest of the week nevertheless
you know hope springs eternal and this
is part of his strategy and his tactic
in the way that he communicates and
tries to negotiate as a businessmen and
on traditional politician with the other
side and he's trying to push him a
little bit expose them call him out in
the hopes that some of that public
pressure will bring them closer towards
what he wants and a deal coming to
fruition I don't know if it's gonna work
because they're old-school politicians
he's old-school business so it's a
little bit two different worlds it's
almost like speaking communicating
operating in different languages but so
far he's been able to get a little bit
of what he wants on this but he's up
against two you know I'm formidable
opponents that have been around the
block yep quite a few times around the
swamp right good film
I don't know I for now let's just call
them Chauncey Chuck in Nancy saves a lot
of time true you should meet with the
guy he is the president I mean even if
it's like Bill me with anybody I suppose
if he showed up in his boxers and
grabbed butts they'd show up oh wow well
I mean they're they're right behind Al
Franken and John Conyers they should
actually meet with President Trump is my
point the best part about that
Trump's press conference was sitting
there with the two empty places last
because that was like an image is worth
everything and him sitting there and
there's the empty seats it's basically
saying they didn't show up for work look
I'm here I am here to work they didn't
show up they're out playing hooky that's
it that's a smart move let me go right
back at you got ya because the media
totally lost it I'm not gonna say melt
it down because you've banned that for
it I did over a number of things one of
those being the Pocahontas comment how
do you feel about that well I think you
know what people hate context Pocahontas
in this context is not derogatory to
Native Americans it's a smear is when
you are derogatory when you use a term
to be derogatory and basically say
they're a lesser person this is actually
the opposite what he's basically saying
here's a metaphor you're playing golf
and your buddy slices it into the woods
and you say nice shot tiger what you're
saying is that tiger is being as a
superior golfer and you're not Tiger
Woods when he was talking when
Pocahontas is basically saying Liz
Warren you're no Pocahontas you
pretended to be you pretended to be a
Native American but you're not a Native
American
these are Native Americans you're an
impostor it would be like watching Chris
Cuomo the media will understand this
Chris Cuomo on CNN and watch them babble
incoherently and you just go good job
Cronkite that's not an insult that's not
an insult to Cronkite it's it's it's
because he's revered the same way
Pocahontas is so that people in the
media they're being disingenuous by
saying that this is a smear it's
actually the opposite of a smear because
it's pointing out that she is nothing
like the person and for it to say that
it's a smear you're being actually
really dishonest it's a lot and that was
unbelievable I'm gonna hire you
my lawyer that was unbelievable not mean
goodness me I'm amazing you didn't just
explode from the spinning that was like
a cyclic oh I'll point out where it's
false and then I'll agree with you but I
think I said what I said there you don't
think that he intended to the mean hurt
with that comment he's actually I think
she's not Pocahontas so it's not a smear
debating her is not demeaning Native
Americans its complementing Native
Americans by pointing out her lamenting
their code talkers right saying about a
what in here reams to be Cherokee or
something about who's from a wholly
different tribe and you're just lumping
them all in it kind he intends to skewer
her yeah I don't think there's any kind
of that's why the rate it's not a race
thank you hurt me in the cyclic way back
and if you this is not an issue of
racism it's the issue of character hmm
and the Democrats could say you're a bad
character because you did this in front
of the Navajo code talkers and this was
an event right I mean you it got
hijacked by this issue or you could say
it's an issue about character because in
order to advance her career
mmm-hmm when she went to Harvard she
said oh yeah I'm gonna check the box
here gets in gets tenure and then
doesn't do that anymore that is an issue
of character it's not one of race okay
before we get to Kimberly and we're
gonna have you react to it let's hear
the media panic over the Pocahontas deal
okay miss panic not only did he say that
which is considered by many a racial
slur he was standing in front of a
portrait of Andrew Jackson who signed
the Indian Removal Act that basically
led to the Trail of Tears and basic a
death march for these people this White
House is Wiley coyote every time they
have a layup they blow themselves up he
says the most bigoted things he says the
most ignorant things and then what makes
it worse is in the end he really has no
clue that he's doing it just because you
say you're not racist doesn't make it so
especially if you say do and defend
racist behavior over and over
and over again especially if you have
lost your credibility by telling
countless lies big and small
so CNN is accusing Trump of losing
credibility that's rich well I don't
know I mean they really want to push
this point it's like they feel like
they've got something here with some
gravitas that they can make the case to
say this is a president that lacks
credibility this is a president the
phrases but they're not this fact does
not support that premise but
nevertheless they're sticking with it
whether it's CNN or whether it's MSNBC
and mica etc that's what they're going
on they're saying okay this is a
president who's being disrespectful he's
being spectral to Native Americans he's
saying this is completely out of control
and trying to tie it back and do the
whole full loop to say this proves in
fact therefore that he doesn't have
credibility he's disrespectful I'm gonna
steal reasoning analogy and say let's
pretend whan that I claimed I was black
just to get into school and then you
made fun of me and said oh yeah
Jesse Jackson over here is Jesse Jackson
a racial slur I don't know but I would
be there I mean this is a guy that said
or they're good people on both sides in
Charlottesville right this is the guy
who goes after the NFL players with some
kind of vigor that makes people think
what's going on makes them think but
less if they're reading it they can read
his mind can't read his mind on no you
know what I didn't say anything racist
about the NFL I think racist thing I
thought I think that he he thinks well
I'm going about to tell you that okay
okay that he finds it just very valuable
politically to attack people of color in
this country and he does so and then say
like all right colors Hillary Clinton
what color is Marco Rubio anybody's news
right we're CNN that attacked and I'm
what I'm saying to you is he finds
political advantage
and value in making whipping boys out of
people of color and he in this Mitch
McConnell in this case I think he went
after her in a way that even Indians
Navajo Indians said was insensitive and
they considered it a slur that's not oh
you have to do that question eighth of a
minute if you pose that question you can
get any answer you want you know Dana
Pelosi bringing it back to the earlier
discussion just tweeted that Trump is
guilty of verbal abuse by saying I guess
crying Chuck and I think that they have
got to figure out a way to meet them
meet him where he is in the gutter
Twitter in the Twitter gutter or
whatever yeah I think that if you are
not going to be able to match him with
wit and you're just gonna say well okay
we're not gonna go to the meeting I
think it is very old-school thinking and
this is one of the problems I think that
the Democrats has is that they are
they've been doing things the same way
for so long and the rest of the world
better or worse whatever has moved on in
different ways there's different ways of
communicating and I just if you showed
the Chuck Schumer speech and he has to
read the entire thing like a dramatic
interpretation rather than just being
able to look into the camera and say I'm
not going to the meeting because you
know what what you said to me was so
insulting and I'm not gonna go work with
you you want to shut down the government
mr. president be my guest
that's not hard dude you don't have to
read all of that and there's no emotion
right that is coming through and it
looks insincere you know what's
interesting you said like they like
Nancy and Chuck or chance he can't meet
him with wit they could probably meet
him halfway
Oh